what a week it was if your name was
cliff Sims two weeks ago you were a
nobody a zero you'd say hey my name's
cliff Sims and people would laugh
because it's a funny name
cliff Sims named after a rock formation
in a computer game but it's amazing what
a tell-all will do for name recognition
cliff Simms joins us now welcome my main
goal here is to have as much fun as the
mooch it was a lot of kind of the game
of thrones backstabbing all the kind of
stuff that he's got a beautiful white
marble bathroom I was a viper - how was
one of them I just saw Sean Spicer
toting a refrigerator out of here with a
cord dangling he got a new chandelier in
there which we paid for for his own with
his own money and the whole atmosphere
is kind of like can you believe it here
we are yeah
well would you look at that suddenly
this guy gets more airtime than a
frisbee at a Phish concert it's not his
fault he's just giving the lockstep
lemmings what they want Trump with all
the trimmings and it doesn't matter of
what they gobble up is the same crap
they inhaled a month before cliff Sims
former White House staffer is now cliff
Sims superstar for a week and why
because he's a think his tell-all has
all the shocking details get this for
example the president uses Tresemme
extra hold hairspray
I know I know fancy five bucks
it's a populist hairspray for average
Joes with orange hair get this Trump
would often point out to oval office
visitors where Clinton and Lewinsky had
sex who wouldn't do that it's like the
most an interesting thing to happen in
the Oval Office it's a stain on our
history and the office rug so the media
waits breathlessly on its hind legs
rubbing up against cliffs knees for
scraps it says more about the media than
Simms who they used like a blow-up doll
punching in and then punching out and
tossing him onto the pile of narcs who
came before him and the media wonders
why we have such a low opinion of the
media because they have a low opinion of
you they want if they think we actually
want this worse they think it matters
because they're still nursing bruises
from 2016 it's why the rest of us felt
satisfied when the Daily Telegraph had
to apologize and pay money to Melania
for making it about her and some of that
crap was taken from a previous tell-all
which contained loads of other imagine
that an unreliable tell-all how could
that be
Luke tell-alls never put the subject in
a good light that's why it's always a
shocking tell-all not a flattering
tell-all as a boss I know I can be a
target of such things they're doing a
documentary on me right now and I got to
tell you it's not pretty what's it like
to work for Greg well one day last year
he made me stay late it was my birthday
and he knew that I wanted to go out with
my friends and he said no you still have
to work anyway I said it was important
and he sent me downtown to go pick up a
package for him and when I got there he
had thrown like the shoe surprise party
for me all my friends and family were
there somehow Abba was there performing
an outdoor concert for all the guests it
was amazing
Erik Estrada was there signing
autographs for people how did Greg know
that Erik Estrada was my long-lost half
brother it's the best birthday I ever
had and when I asked people how you know
Greg pulled this off and why wasn't he
there they told me he was at my
apartment watering my plants because he
knew I wouldn't be able to do it that
night I mean what a guy that wasn't so
bad
fact is you clap for me not for him not
over basically a tell all relies on
trash and a low-level garbage man who
needs money to offer such trash because
no publisher is gonna fork out the dough
to a book called meetings with Trump
he's awesome trashing the subject is the
business model which they've now
stretched for two years and you can't do
a tell-all about a boring person you
know chapter one
he stretched imagine a tell-all about
Mike Pence
rumor has it his wife once caught him
looking at another woman it was the
Virgin Mary nope if you lived any kind
of life there's gonna be dirt me I got
more dirt than El Chapo's fingernails
here's what my staff is saying about me
so you great work together for a while
are you guys close one time he invited
me to his office it was late we were
alone one thing led to another and he
found my cat he'd just gone missing the
day before I was so grateful then when I
got home I saw that he made a donation
to a local hospital in my name he never
even mentioned it he also did my laundry
that could have been worse so the media
gets its injection of gossip and before
it's debunked they've already moved on
to the next book clip
Simms was a low-level hack but they
could go even lower I can't wait to see
the next books you know grounds for
impeachment as told by the White House
gardener
boiling over I burn Trump steaks and 12
other chapters from the White House chef
inside Trump
mm-wha with fold-out colonoscopies by
the president's gastroenterologist fact
is everyone has something to say and
frankly I got to say that worries me as
Greg you ever gotten mad for anything
yeah one time I was really late my train
was delayed and by the time I got there
Greg was in my office and he looked
pissed then he looked at me and he said
I thought you were dead and he got up
and he he hugged me the biggest best hug
I've ever had better than any my dad's
hugs even and then he pulled out his
wallet and give me $600 for no reason
5-line the richer the life the juicier
the tell-all which is why nobody will
ever care about the Jim Acosta tell-all
by the way it's called my angry cure for
sleep apnea because no one in the media
will ever get a tell-all like the ones
they give to Trump what's the difference
between the press and Trump he's
interesting the media not even close
well except for me so you know Greg for
a long time do you have any stories oh
yeah sure
back in 2012 I was on my way over to
Greg's house and right as I was about to
knock on the door I heard screaming and
I knew it wasn't Greg screams because I
know Greg screams but it just kept
getting louder and louder and louder so
I just kicked in the door and what I saw
was unbelievable Greg was delivering a
baby
apparently when he's not at Fox Greg
volunteers as a midwife
oh I apologized about the door and he
said oh don't worry about that old thing
I was going to have it replaced here
have a hoagie oh he gave me $600 so
you've ever had any problems working
with Greg oh yeah last month I was
pretty convinced Greg had a drinking
problem he would only drink seven
glasses of water a day and when I told
him he should drink eight he took my
advice and then doubled my salary now I
can quit my night job at the refinery
and spend more time volunteering at the
orphanage Greg founded so you were with
Greg in the early days any stories from
back then
oh yeah well I don't really like to talk
about it that much but back in the early
days there were a lot of late nights and
Gregg got me hooked on drugs
baby aspirin it's now everyday I take a
baby aspirin because it reduces your
risk of heart disease you know I didn't
know this at the time but before the GG
show Greg practiced medicine at this
orphanage he founded he also gave me
$600 once homeless people give him
change comedian Jimmy Fela Price saying
her name drunk I dare you Fox Business
Network reporter Christina parts analyst
she cheered at the end of Old Yeller
host of the tiresome tim podcast cat Tim
the Eiffel Tower is this golf club the
former WWE Superstar my massive
sidekicking the host of MPC about Cyrus
boom Jimmy good to see you dressed up
again today's man is suiting you they're
killing it man don't assume my gender by
the way I know I'm sorry about that so
um these tools don't they have to step
it up a bit because I feel like they're
retreads what's going on and I'll be
honest I haven't read any of the
tell-alls I'm waiting for the box set to
come out but what's going on is yes when
you do go in to sell one of these books
you have to get the publisher interested
right so they do a lot of embellishing I
mean I know this I have a book out yeah
it's called follow that car if you like
reading at a third-grade level you will
love this book but it also at the same
time as you read the inner workings of
this administration and what goes on in
the White House you're kind of
appreciative of it because could you
imagine how boring the tell-all is about
Hillary Clinton would be oh my god the
only interesting chapter it's pretty
drunk yeah the only interesting chapter
would be when all the computers got a
virus because Huma let Anthony Weiner
use the Wi-Fi I thought it would have
been like which colored power suits your
to wear for that day
spoken like a fan of the power yes
there's quite a power suit it's a onesie
Cristina you're a business person or so
I'm told
um is this this is actually a business I
mean Trump is basically revitalizing the
the tell-alls
yeah why not capitalize on this you're
seeing a literally political sales for
books or politic book crime 25% just
last year in 2018 so even if you just
saw him drive by or that you're the
gardener the cook why not write a book
about it like you mentioned at the top
of the show they're capitalizing
everybody everybody's written one and
I've read one of them feared by Bob
Woodward there was nothing in it that
was anything exciting or anything you
could really write about yeah I was
gonna ask you cat who would you rather
be the subject of a tell-all or the
writer of a tell-all and then I realized
you actually occupy the same space
because you're like your own tell-all
yeah I really kind of just where all my
secrets on my sleeve and then I'm like
why doesn't anyone like me you know this
this wasn't shocking it was more of the
same right like things were a little
crazy in the White House yes we knew
that already that's really like someone
writing a tell-all about the Kardashians
that was like they wear makeup you know
really not that shocking be shocking if
somebody came out with a book that said
I worked for Trump and I was bored and
he ate a lot of salad player that would
really really shocked me but the thing
is no matter how many of these books
come out it doesn't really matter
because no one really cares the people
who support the president they're gonna
support him no matter what's going on in
the White House because they like his
policy proposals they like his agenda
and that's all that really matters to
them so it's kind of a waste it is it is
I mean I will say this Tyrus I enjoy the
little tidbits but they mean nothing to
me that's it they mean it's a big like
way that says really really great yes
little tidbits and telling me nothing -
yes what do you - what are you trying to
infer I don't know because I wasn't
allowed my my tell-all wasn't up there
right now do you tell I'm crazy oh I
thought I didn't get any you asked every
employee yes no one even knew who Hawley
was they do now
not asked me I was oh not after don't
live in New York I've been here since
Wednesday sir you're a little must be
nice you know mr. president you could
take a page out of the gutfeld blog he
did his own tell-all yes he directed it
he produced it I don't know if you guys
noticed but that muffled voice that was
holding those people hostage for hours
that was great
he asked them he sat what they talked
about how great he was
yeah that's physic you what's the name
of your orphanage never caught the name
of it it's it's Gregg's orphanage
Gregg's orphanage google it any way you
want to Google back yes so I guess my
point is yeah tell also yeah thank you
for that welcome all right
that leaves more time for the next
segment all right before we go an update
on the gutfeld monologues live the show
in Tampa is sold out I've never sold out
anything the tickets for all other shows
are still available special guests huh
salut I did not sell you out go to G
gutfeld comm for ticket information